Tony Stark: We're the Avengers.
We gotta finish this.
Narrator: Marvel just dropped
another teaser for "Avengers: Endgame,"
and while it doesn't show much,
it does reveal a few new
tidbits about the movie.
Warning: possible spoilers ahead.
Bruce Banner: If we do this,
we'd be going in shorthanded.
Narrator: The trailer starts out
with the team deciding to go after Thanos
to avenge their friends.
We see the Benatar approaching New York,
then Rocket and Nebula
sitting on its steps.
Both have suffered devastating losses
with Nebula losing her sister
and Rocket losing his entire team,
including his pal Groot.
Rocket: No, no, no, no!
Groot,
no.
Narrator: It looks like Rocket
is wearing his normal outfit,
which is important for what
comes later in the trailer.
Tony and Pepper hug. We don't
know how long he's been gone
or how long it took for him to get back,
but this is a reunion fans
have been waiting for.
Is this them saying goodbye again
as he goes to take on Thanos?
Hawkeye has a lot more tattoos
than the last time we saw him.
It looks like someone is
not taking the snap well.
Has he lost his entire family?
In the group shot,
Rocket is the only one
suited up for action.
Is this when the team decides
to finally take the battle to Thanos?
This one's for all the fans
shipping Tony and Steve.
Tony: You trust me?
Steve Rogers: I do.
Narrator: Next, we see
most of the remaining
Avengers on the Benatar.
Rocket is not wearing the
jumpsuit he had on earlier,
and the team is not wearing the spacesuits
we saw in an earlier trailer.
There's also no Hawkeye, Nebula,
Ant-Man, or Tony in this shot.
Are they somewhere else on the ship
or taking care of a different mission?
Black Widow has the same short, blond hair
she had in "Infinity War."
With this trailer and others
showing longer, more red hair,
does this take place
soon after "Infinity War"
with other parts of the
movie happening much later?
It has been pointed out
that Tony's hair looks a
lot grayer in some shots.
Could the team be going to both
space and the Quantum Realm?
The movie is three hours long,
so there's definitely time for both.
We get a voiceover of Thanos saying:
Thanos: You could not live
with your own failure.
Narrator: Then a shot of Thanos' ship.
It looks like Nebula and Rhodey
are both looking at Thanos'
giant Sanctuary II ship,
so it seems Nebula was
elsewhere on the Benatar
in that group shot.
Thanos beams down the way he did
before he had the Space Stone.
In "Infinity War," he used the Space Stone
to teleport around, but
it looks like he's back
to using his ship's beam transport.
Does this mean he no
longer has the Space Stone?
Or is it not working?
Finally, we see Tony, Cap, and Thor
approaching Thanos on
what looks like Titan,
where Tony and the others
fought him in "Infinity War."
Will this be some sort of time warp?
Was Thanos unable to restore
Titan to its former glory?
What do you think, did we miss anything?
Let us know in the comments.